in 1994 The Little Rascals hit theaters
but wasn't a huge box-office hit instead
it became a favorite among Millennials
due to frequent airings on cable TV it's
a sweet low-key outing but it's a
standout because of its cast of
delightful child actors so where is the
cast of The Little Rascals now Oh Travis
Tedford previously seen as a tiny
pitchman for Welch's grape juice travis
Tedford played Spanky leader of The
Little Rascals after appearing in
forgettable movies like the 13th floor
Tedford moved back to his home state of
Texas in 2002 and now works in marketing
for a large credit union Brandan bug
Hall the actor who played the lovelorn
alfalfa followed up Little Rascals with
appearances in films like the aptly
titled with stupids and played Eddie
Munster and the Munsters scary little
Christmas bug hauls continue to work
steadily appearing on CASL CSI Miami and
Criminal Minds in the 2014 directed DVD
The Little Rascals save the day he has a
cameo as an ice-cream man Ross Begley of
all his co-stars Ross Bailey who played
buckwheat enjoyed the most high-profile
acting career back when sitcoms brought
in cute tykes to boost ratings Bailey
appeared as Nicki - precocious little
kid in The Fresh Prince of bel-air he
co-starred with Will Smith once more in
Independence Day Begley later took a
break from acting and recently earned
his degree in film studies Brittney
Ashton Holmes Darla charmed audiences as
the object of alfalfa's affections as
well as the target of the he-man woman
haters Club it was Britney Ashton Holmes
first ever role and has remained her
most prominent she retired from the
screen at the ripe old age of 7 and is
pursuing a degree in political science
Blake McIver Yuen Waldo was the villain
of The Little Rascals as the son of a
wealthy oil baron played by Donald Trump
post Little Rascals
Blakeman Kyra Ewing voice to Eugene on
Hey Arnold and host the people's couch
he's also worked with the It Gets Better
Project and funded the recording of an
album by working as a go-go dancer Ewing
opted to keep Waldo's amazing hair into
adulthood which is simply awesome
Kevin Jamal woods the kid who played
stymie continued acting sporadically
throughout childhood appearing in two
distantly nineties things he voiced a
puppy and babe and guest-starred on
Walker Texas Ranger these days Kevin
Jamal woods is an audio engineer and
music producer in Texas Zachary map read
porky stole a lot of scenes as Spanky's
little brother and devoted assistant
it's the only acting Zachary Mabrey ever
did now he's a public sector accountant
in the Dallas area
Samsa Letta if there are a bunch of kids
getting into crazy adventures you need a
bully to bug him right that's movie
logic 101 since playing butch and the
little rascals Samsa Letta has done a
lot of voiceover work particularly for
recess rocket power and the video game
call of duty black ops
he's also a singer-songwriter and played
in a band called Jubilee PD to dog peds
last on screen credit comes from a 2012
documentary series called American dog
and considering that the Little Rascals
was released more than 20 years ago it's
safe to say PD has since been sent to a
nice farm upstate where he can run and
play all day thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos at the one you just
saw and leave us a comment let us know
which rascal was your favorite
[Music]